[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar technology platforms for
monoclonal antibody development and
production
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
sinobiological to learn more visit
sinobiological.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker amy
sheng phd technical account manager
cynobiological u.s
amy you may now begin your presentation
welcome everybody i am amy
the technical account manager of
xenobiological
welcome to this webinar
in the next 30 to 40 minutes i will walk
you through the development of
monoclonal antibody
we will briefly review the history of
monoclonal antibody i will use map to
simplify it sometimes
then proceed to discuss three
technologies we use hybridoma technology
phage display technology and single b
cell antibody technology
let us take an overview of map
development
it has been a long history since the
discovery of antibodies
however the map this development goes
back to 1975 when the first immortal
hybridoma cells producing an antibody
against the sheep red blood cells was
generated
map r d platforms then keep optimizing
enabling the generation of thus the
volume of antibiotic clones with
surprising speed in the following years
the first antibody drug was approved by
fda in 1986
since then numerous maps with multiple
formats such as chemeric
humanized by specific have been applied
to therapeutics
by today more than 135 map drugs have
been approved or under regulatory review
for treating cancers
autoimmune diseases viral infections and
etc
there is no doubt that more and more
will be developed and approved for
therapeutics in the future
among the top 10 drugs by global sales
there are multiple maps for
either for autoimmune disorders or for
cancers
again proving the effects of maps in
treating those diseases
also explaining why map development is
such a hot topic both in science or in
business
map can be used as therapeutics as
mentioned in the previous slide
or as a reagent in diagnostics like
those in pregnancy tests or covet
antigen rapid test
maps are also widely used in biomedical
research for qualitative or quantitative
characterizing targets
generally speaking the technologies for
map discovery have been developed for
four generations
the first is the hybridoma technologies
to develop immortal antibody producing
cells
the second is the generation of chemic
or humanized map by phage display
the third generation involves using
single b cell sorting techniques to
obtain antibodies with native pairing
the most recent developed platform is
using naive antibody library for like
antibody screening which is most time
efficient way
it is not like smartphone that when the
new generation comes out the older one
get discontinued all these platforms are
used extensively in different scenarios
and today we will go through the basics
of first three techniques hybridoma
immunized phage display screening and
single b cell sorting
there are mainly four steps in hybridoma
generation
immunization cell fusion
clone screening and antibody production
immunization involves injecting the
target immunology into animals
it could be rat
mouse or rabbit
entirely controlled schedule to maximize
the immune response
once the serum title tells that the
animal is ready antibody producing b
cells will be harvested
and fused to myeloma cells
selections will be applied to remove
unfused myeloma cells and our fused b
cells will die off after couple of days
leaving only hyperdoma cells in the
culture
then these cells will be subjected to
screening by elisa flow cytometry or
cell-based assay etc to obtain the best
clones
with the hybridoma cell line antibody
can be produced either by in vivo
production through mouse ocities or in
buying vitro production through cell
culture
immunogens are not restricted to one
type
from dna to
protein to cells they can all trigger
immune response with careful design of
experiments
in fact the choose of which format to
immunize strongly influences the results
how the antibody generated be useful in
different applications
for example with the same target
antibody clone obtained from protein
immunogen may have higher chance to work
well in elisa or flow cytometry than
that obtained from peptide immunogen
since the latter may only recognize
linear aptos that might not be
accessible in the natural conformations
besides the standard peptide and protein
immunogen we can also obtain antibodies
using
non-protein immunogens such as cells or
dna or viruses
signal biological build its legacy
around recombinant production therefore
we prefer to use proteins as immunogens
various production platforms can be used
to generate the immunogens
however many production is not very
straightforward and needs
troubleshooting for specific cases
potential risks in the production
includes and not restricted to
low expression
aggregation or degradation of the
protein
the protein has very poor solubility
or it has high batch to batch variation
okay how should we tackle this
we can try different plasmids to help
increasing production of the protein
xenobiological has multiple proprietary
vectors that have been optimized for
recombinant production
cultural conditions can also be
optimized to solve problems such as low
yield
degradation
aggregation
etc
the couple of case studies here
are shown the time of culture
is correlated to the degree of
degradation in this particular of
protein
so if we want high purity non-degraded
protein we need to shorten the culture
time
this is an example of vacuolovirus
insect cell expression system
by optimizing the moi
multiplicity of infection a higher level
of expression can be observed
immunization strategies determines if
the good serum tighter can be reached
which is absolutely required for
obtaining positive clones
different immunization rules
can be
used
among them ip
meaning abdominal and subcutaneous are
the easiest thus more widely used
for immunization schedules
you can use
you can stick to a routine immunization
which starts with first immunization
followed by sequential boosters
each time with standard amount of
immunogens
or you can do a rapid immunization with
shorter time
and the larger amount of immunogen
adjuvants are also important in the
experiments especially for the target
that exhibits low immune immunogenicity
a good choice of adjuvant can compensate
that and increase the chance of
obtaining positive clones
about cell fusions there are two methods
one is pack mediated cell fusion
the mechanism is to use pack usually
with average molecular weight of 1500
to induce membrane rearrangement and
cause the merge of two adjacent cells
the key factor for fusion efficiency are
choice of a pack
concentration of chemicals and cells
incubation time and temperature of
fusion
the advantage of this method is low cost
and down manually thus does not require
any special equipment
however the disadvantage is that the
efficiency is low and process can cause
great damage to the cells
the other way is electro fusion
electro fusion has gained popularity and
we add synobiological meaning uses this
method
the cells are positioned on a
point contact state and membranes are
rearranged and fused under stimulation
of an electric pulse
despite the need of the electrical
fusion instrument the advantages of the
electrofusion are very obvious
it allows for more control over
conditions higher efficiency of the cess
and as well as better growth properties
following fusion
moreover it can be
performed with a smaller number of cells
here is some data showing the electro
fusion versus the pack fusion you can
see that for the same target electro
fusion can generate much higher
number of positive clones
and higher cell availability after the
experiments especially for the different
targets such as number five no positive
clones were obtained from pack fusion
but it is doable through electrical
fusion
after the fusion extensive screening
experiments are needed for two purposes
one is to isolate the clones that show
high affinity specificity and yield
second is to ensure the monoclonality
in this figure an indirect elisa was
demonstrated the target is coded on the
solid support or say a lysoplate
antibody in the sample will recognize
the target and bind to that the
interaction then will be detected by
secondary antibody labeled with an
enzyme that characterizes colorimetric
reactions
the screening usually takes place in
couple of the rounds at least three
rounds to make sure that the best clones
are isolated for the later experiment
besides eliza other screenings might be
also used in different strategies to
increase the successful rate
for example if we need to develop an
antibody that will be used in flow
cytometry we can use flow cytometry in
the title test
the clone screening and the sub cloning
to ensure that the final positive clone
will be ideal for this application
at last as mentioned antibodies can be
used either by in vivo production
through societies or by in vitro
production through cell culture
ascites production involves injection of
hybridoma cells into mice and collect
ascites from for antibody purification
it is less controllable and has issues
regarding animal welfare
the final product might also be
contaminated by host proteins or even
animal viruses
in visual production involves culturing
the hybridoma cells in flasks bottles or
bioreactors
currently in bio industrial production
has been optimized in which serum free
culture and large-scale production are
possible so it is getting more and more
variable
next we will go through immunized phase
display techniques
to start we need to understand the
biology of the phage
there are multiple type of phages can be
used in phage display
such as t4 number and the m13
bacteriophage
m13 shown over here
has been used most extensively
it contains non-essential regions in its
chromosome
so extraogenous dna can be introduced
moreover proteins are presented on their
surface
making them accessible to the target of
interaction
in the phage display technique the
feature of phage presenting a target
protein outside is fully utilized
here the graph showing a recombinant
phase displaying single chain fv akascfv
which is the basic of a library
so let's talk about how we do the phage
explain
first antibody sequence information is
obtained from the b cells
from spleen or peripheral blood or bloom
arrow then constructed into single chain
fv
it is inserted into phage made
a phage made like plasmid contains
antibiotic marker gene coding the
antibody g3p fusion protein and regions
required for m13 chromosome replication
an m13 helper
phage is usually used for packaging of
the phage meat particles in e-coli
once the library of phages displaying
different scfv is constructed it is
ready for
screening
phage display screening is a high
throughput process including multiple
rounds of five steps
addition of the phased library into the
antigen
phage with a single v
single chain fv binds to the antigen
washing off those non-binders
bond phases then are eluted by the
enzymatic digestion using trypsin or by
acid or base
the last
amplification of those binders
after couple of the rounds
once the best clones are identified the
sequences of the single chain fee will
be cloned into expression vectors to
make full length antibodies
there are a couple of bowel panning
methods used in the screen
emulized immobilized method in which
antigens are coated on the plates are
most often used
however in some cases target might
change conformation if directly coated
on the plate
in this case we would use ink solution
bio painting to present epitopes better
to the phage there are also other ways
of vaping methods used widely
consisted of so many steps and so many
rounds fish display is not a simple
experiment and there are places can go
wrong and can be optimized when dealing
with special cases
we have established a mature strategy
when it comes to troubleshooting for
phase display changing the antigen
coding conditions such as director
coding or about alternated antigen
captured
by immunologist streptavidin will help
the
results careful selection of elisa
plates blocking reagents dilution
gradient of library
coloring solutions and plain
concentrations are also ways to improve
by opening results
we have developed a long list of rabbit
map by fish display they have high
affinity and sensitivity specificity and
low background
there
therefore besides the regular
application of western blood elisa flow
cytometry
they are excellent regions for ihc
and also they are ideal for
map generation against the mouse
antigens
besides a regular protein target we also
utilize phage display for anti-idiotic
antibody development
anti-id antibodies are antibiotics that
can recognize the antigen binding
region of the antibody drug
there are inhibitory anti-idab that
blocks the binding of the antibody drug
to the target and also non-inhibitory
anti-idf
that detects the total drug
or the bound drug exclusively
due to the application of anti-id apps
differ it is of great importance to
differentiate them doing screening
one step is to test the serum title and
pick the one with desired binding
performance
another step is doing the phage display
different
screenings such as competitive screening
or complex specific screening can be
applied to obtain a clone with either
inhibitory or non-inhibitory binding
these are results of our anti-id app
development towards anti-cd33
interleukin 17 reference antibodies the
resulting anti-id clones showed no
reactivity towards human igg and isotype
control but great binding compared with
the reference antibody suggesting that
those clones specifically target the
ideotopic regions
both inhibitory and non-inhibitory
clones and paired antibody
successfully obtained from the
experiment
next we're going to talk about how
central biological applied phage display
in nanobody development
nanobodies are antibodies that have only
heavy chains and a lot have one constant
region so they only have ch2 and ch3
which make the whole molecule is
generally speaking smaller than the
regular igg they have also better
solubility
and higher penetration rate into tissue
thus has gained a lot of attention for
therapeutic discovery
the development starts with blood
collection from immunized nama or
alpacas
vhh sequences then cloned into the phage
mid to construct the library
antigen antigen-specific vhh are then
identified by repeated rounds of a
binding washing and illusion
at last the best clones will be
expressed as vhh or constructed into
full length and characterize their
purity and affinity and etc
let us take a look of a case study
regarding the development of antibody in
the adc
antibody drug conjugates
adcs are intended to target and kill
tumor cells the antibody part can't
contribute to the specificity and
affinity or sometimes induced
therapeutic response
while the drug part also called payload
it contributes to the cytotoxicity
they are linked by a linker
that is stable in circulation and are
able to release the payload at the
target
after the antibody attached themselves
to the surface of the cancer cells
they will be absorbed and internalized
internalized the payload then kills the
cancer cells or even take an effect in
the tumor and micro environment
here let's talk talk about the target
tumor associated calcium signal
transducer 2 aka chop 2 or epithelium
glycoprotein 1.
it is a carcinoma associated antigen
that is pretty popular right now as a
drug target
it is a transmembrane protein that
transduces that intracellular calcium
signal and also acts as a cell surface
receptor
the expression of trop2 is
very low in normal tissue however
elevated expression has been observed in
many type of cancers making it a very
good natural target for targeted cancer
therapies to obtain good clones for
anti-drug antibodies we introduce the
cells into the screening process
using flow cytometry we can see that
clones and biological developed has
great specificity and affinity towards
cancer cells and almost no binding
taught towards the epithelium cells
regarding the inter
internalization the efficiency is
comparable or even higher than the
reference antibody
using fluorescence we are able to
visualize the internalization of the
antibody before the internalization you
can see that more fluorescence can be
seen outside of the cell perfectly
outlining the cells right
after one hour you can see more
fluorescence can be seen inside of the
cells indicating the successful
internalization of the antibody
also it is reported
that
at an affinity towards target a range of
1 to 10 animal the efficiency of
antibody internalization is the highest
the clones we developed all fall in this
range
also proving that they can be a good
candidate for adcs
next we will talk about a single b cell
antibody development platform
first let's review the immunology 101
for a minute
that's showing in the illustration
vdj recombination occurs in pro-b cells
in the bone marrow
pre-bcr b-cell receptors then emerges on
the surface in pre-b cells
once the immune to b cells travels to
peripheral lymphoid tissues
the final phases of b-cell maturation
occur
the mature b cells will carry igd
and igm on their services
and those mature b cells bond to
foreign antigens will be get will get
activated
then give rise to plasma cells for
antibody secretion
and memory b cells
who carry the b cell receptors single b
cell sorting starts with collecting b
cells from
spleen or
pbmc from immunized animals or infected
patients
to enrich antigen-specific memory b
cells b cell receptors on the
surface can be used to bind an antigen
that is usually coupled to a
fluorescence dye
followed by a sorting of the stained
memory b cells by facts
then the b cells can be lysed directly
to obtain rna or they can be put into
culture
the supernatant can be used to isolate
clones with best performance
variable regions
they are cloned into vectors to
for recombinant production of the
antibody and later they can be validated
by various assays
the advantages of single b-cell platform
is that the capacity of screening
thousands and thousands of clones per
round does make it more time-saving
compared to hybridoma techniques
second
natural cognate vh and vl pairing is
preserved making it
has a higher chance to heat a clone with
high affinity
here are the flow cytometry results
showing how we select the single b cells
by flow cytometry from two species of
animals
mouse and rabbit
for mouse
since they are panels fully established
and available we sort those cd 19 plus
igg ign minus and igg one plus
and igd mine uh minus cells
uh in addition as i mentioned antigen
labeled with fluorescence is used to
sort out those antigen specific b-cells
for rabbit
we use ssc and fsc to sort out
lymphocytes first
because there are there aren't many
established markers to use and then we
select those are igm minus and
igg plus
substitutes and those specific to
antigens
then antibody gene amplification is
performed to clone the variable regions
of heavy and light chains to expression
vectors for recombinant productions
let's take a look of
case study for antibodies used in
immunotherapy involving t cells
there are two main categories
agonists and antagonists
um agonists those are
ones can activate the target and um
antagonists
can suppress or block the targets
aux40 and its ligand partner x40l are
expressed on activated cd4 and cd8
t-cells
stimulating ox-40 has shown it to be a
candidate for therapeutic immunization
strategies for cancer and infectious
disease agonist
antibodies for ox40
have to show high agonistic activities
as well as
good affinity and specificity in cell or
animal models
among here we screened thousands of
b-cells
and isolated 300 elisa positive
clones among them 10 clones showed lower
blocking activity compared to reference
antibodies
then we examined the agonistic effect of
the antibodies in the cell and found our
antibodies work similarly or even better
than the reference antibodies
besides that affinity of them have been
shown to excel io2 secretion by t cells
also shows increased upon the treatment
of our antibodies suggesting that our
clones can successfully trigger
therapeutic responses and be a good
candidate for antibody drugs
there's another case study we performed
on tigid antibody discovery using single
b cloning
pcr was done directly after sorting
we were able to obtain multiple clones
that perform equally to or better than
the reference antibody within a
surprising short time 26 days
to summarize we have discussed the three
platforms of antibody development
they all have its own pros and cons
and hybridoma technology the one with
the longest history produces the
antibodies with native and chain tearing
and antibodies undergo in vivo and
infinity maturation
however the time and capacity are
limiting factors for large volume
screening
and also genetic drift in the antibiotic
coding region
can cause batch to batch variation and
unstability of the cell lines
phage display and single b sorting have
solved the problem of long screening
time and low capacity to certain extent
antibody sequences are obtained directly
thus production and batch to batch
difference can be controlled more
tightly
the disadvantages of phage display
are that antibodies may not be
native pairing
the library size is dependent on the e
coli transformation efficiency
and for single b cell sorting the single
cell sorting equipment is required and
thus there is higher cost usually
besides antibodies for b
sorting are not
available for all the species of the
animals
at our cyanobiological we can offer
antibody development for anti-d
nanobody
by specific antibodies antagonists
agonists and adc antibodies
phospho-specific antibodies and etc
we have rich experience and many many
successful cases for those projects
after antibodies are developed developed
we also have the capacity to
characterize them by various cellular
biochemical or biophysical acids
biological is one stop reagent and crow
service provider we have more than 6 500
catalog proteins more than 14 000
antibodies
32 000 cdna products and etc
our crawl services cover recombinant
expression for proteins or antibodies
antibody development and i got
customized assay development
our product has been featured in many
high
impact factor journals and has spread
their footprints in more than 90
countries
we truly hope that our effort can help
your work and the research and exert
more and more beneficial influences on
the scientific and human health field
thank
you thank you amy for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
you talked about mouse rabbit llama
antibody development
how does the how does the choice of
species affect the results
um thank you yes
since the structure of the antibodies
from different species might defer the
results could also vary a lot
mouse antibodies are more conventional a
lot of research were using mouse
antibodies just fine
then the development platforms for a
rapid antibodies get established and
they got popular for that rabbits can
recognize a broader diversity of
antigens
so it is a better system to develop
antibodies that are less immunogenic in
mouse
also the antibodies are with higher
affinity and specificity compared to
those developed from mice
so you may be able to get a cleaner and
prettier ihc image if you switch from
mouse to rabid antibodies
moreover rabbit igg does not
differentiate into different subclasses
so which will make the experiments
easier
rapid antibodies are more stable and
usually have longer shelf life which
also can make the lab managers happier
nama shark etc mentioned they have
distinct structural difference in
antibodies so they are able to bind to
epitopes that are less accessible or
antigenic
so they can be used to bind to cavities
in the target and modulate the enzymatic
activity of the target
also the blood clearance of labeled
antibodies is very fast for vhh thus it
is very convenient to use it as a
non-invasive
in vivo imaging
so when we at the when we talk about
what species to choose when we're trying
to develop antibodies we definitely need
to think carefully about application
what kind of results we want to obtain
in the end uh time and sometimes even
budget to when we choose a species
all right thank you
next question
what's the usual timeline for antibody
development
um it is definitely a long process up to
a couple of months um it starts with
antigen preparation different antigens
may require different timeline and
process
for example recombinant and proteins may
take up to three to four weeks to make
then standard
immunization can take eight to ten weeks
if we use rapid immunization it can be
shortened to to do within a month
um still timeline for screening and
antibody production various depends on
which platforms to choose
single b sorting is the shortest
shortest one you can obtain the
antibodies as soon as within a month
after immunization completes
however for hybridoma and phage display
may take up to two months to get
monoclonal antibody with demonstrated
reactivity and
specificity after the immunization
okay thank you
next question
if the naive antibody screening is
available and can produce antibody with
shorter time
are methods with immunization still
needed
and the answer is yes naive entered by
the library even though it is very very
convenient in shortening the discovery
time there are
issues about it
the library may be less easily
accessible especially human library and
secondly the antibodies screened from
the naive library may have less affinity
towards the target so we may still need
to perform affinity at maturation after
to improve the infinity of selected
clones
thus the antibody development using
immunization is still going to be
prevalent unless those two issues got
resolved
okay
next question
how does the recombinant antibody
compare to the traditionally developed
antibody
in nature
antibody developed from phage display or
single b or recombinant antibodies since
cloning of antibodies sequences is
involved
there are advantages over antibodies
from hybridoma are
many couple of points one is the
stability we can have cells expressing
the antibodies in bulk in very short
time and
culture them in huge bioreactors
so it is very common to produce
gram-level antibodies in our facility
second in vitro animal-free production
so as i mentioned some antibodies from
hybridoma are still produced using a
mouse ascites
for ant recombinant antibodies we can
fully use in vitro systems and have
serum free medium so no contaminates
from and animals
thirdly is possible to perform high
throughput production and screening in
the
recombinant antibody platforms for
example if we want to fully humanize or
perform affinity maturation our antibody
we can propose a list of different
mutations on the sequences and by
recombinant technology we can easily
produce all the candidate antibodies and
screen the one we want
the last one is that the recombinant
antibody has higher consistency and less
batch to batch variation
all right thank you
next question
what is the biggest obstacle for current
antibody development
i think now the biggest obstacle is
still the time of developing and
establishing a good clone
you know when the pandemic just started
a lot of people were talking about
isolating neutralizing antibodies so
even though the whole world is
were speeding up and thousands of lab
were focusing on that
only after it took one year to
identify so one solution to short
shorten the time is to use naive library
as we mentioned before
another solution is to use computational
analysis to obtain the noble sequence
information from currently available
data
and by high throughput sequencing to
sorry and by high throughput screening
to find a glue clone
in hope to respond with shortest time
thank you
next question
what information is absolutely needed
when i want to develop an antibody
we need to know the target as much as
possible of course
what's in nature is that a small
molecule is a protein dna virus etc
if it's a protein what's the sequence is
a purity or stability good enough for
immunization is a agent or immunogenic
enough to trigger antibody production in
animals
this will determine how we perform the
immunization experiments
a second will be what's the application
for the antibodies as mentioned antibody
developer used for western blood elisa
or flow cytometry might use different
formats of antigens
and use methods in testing and
validation
so furthermore other informations may be
needed for specific cases
for example we had cases to develop an
antibody that recognized human version
target but not the mouse or rabbit or
monkey version
these two targets have high percentage
in the conserved region
in this case we would need to start with
much higher amount of positive clones
and let them go through extensive
counter screening to ensure the high
reactivity towards the target a human
target but to have lowest cross
reactivity towards the mouse or rabbit
or monkey
so in a word antibody development is is
a lengthy complex and highly uh
customerized experiments it is not just
about getting the antibodies but also
about how it helps the design of whole
project that use this antibodies so
therefore more information we have in
the beginning the better antibodies we
can obtain in the end
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
how many specific clones can you obtain
from single b sorting
it depends on the amount of cells sorted
usually given premises of good title and
under standard protocol the specific
clones can be 10 percent to 40 percent
of sorted cells
sometimes even higher
thank you again amy for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor
sinobiological for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you